florian ce lost vient de s'installer sur
ces terrains communaux de mont près
chambord il a fait ses toutes premières
récoltes en avril ce jeune maraîcher bio
fournit des écoles des ehpad est
désormais le nouveau magasin de
producteurs de bois ça sécurise son
installation
c'est une aventure de groupe incroyable
et ça me permet de l'envisager l'acd
isation de mon salarié à temps plein à
partir du mois de mars de l'année
prochaine
autrement je le regardais uniquement à
mi temps mais grâce à un projet comme ça
il est évident qu'il pourra passer à
temps plein en tant qu'associé d'eau
près des paysans florian espèrent que 80
% de sa production sera vendu dans le
nouveau magasin de producteurs avenue de
châteaudun à blois auprès des paysans
compte quatorze producteurs associés du
loir et cher pour eux c'est la meilleure
solution pour gagner leur vie
les producteurs fixe chacun leur prix
puisqu'on est en dépôt vente donc on est
propriétaire de notre produit jusqu'à sa
vente est donc le pour les associés de
magasin prend 20% 2
demain pour le fonctionnement c'est plus
cher qu'on vend très ferme mais par
contre
vous êtes moins cher quand même que dans
les supermarchés les boucheries
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire
voilà c'est la vente directe du
producteur au consommateur en plus des
producteurs associés 35 à porter
fournissent d'autres produits variés du
loir et cher ce qui assure un large
choix aux clients
ça permet bd lait les producteurs de la
région
je trouve que c'est important parce que
c'est ce qui se passe tout le monde tous
les paysans besoin d'elle les prix sont
un peu plus cher mais bon faut pour
prendre aussi qu'il faut qu'ils gagnent
leur vie aussi comme tous et ça évite
les intermédiaires
le magasin auprès des paysans est ouvert
du mercredi au samedi il est tenu par
deux salariés et les producteurs
viennent assurer des permanences
plusieurs demi-journées par mois